MALE SPEAKER: I met
Clint after a TED talk
that he gave a few weeks ago.
I found the talk
incredibly touching.
I have young children.
They are 13 and 15.
And it reminded me, again, how
much we have to go as a country
in truly creating an environment
where kids could be kids,
and we all just had
a world in which
we were judged by our actions.
And there we could
aspire to be everything
that we wanted to be.
I don't think Clint needs
a special introduction.
He is presented at some
of the most amazing stages
in the world, including TED.
He's a PhD candidate
at Harvard and a winner
of the of the 2014 national
poetry slam championship.
And I'm sure we're going to have
both an amazing talk from him
and a great Q&A session that
Damien's going to mediate.
With that, Clint.
[APPLAUSE]
CLINT SMITH: I appreciate it.
Thanks so much.
How's everybody doing?
Come on, you guys
work at Google.
How's everybody doing?
[LAUGHTER]
There we go.
You should be like,
ah, this is awesome.
Food is free everywhere.
So thank you so
much for having me.
Like he said, my
name is Clint Smith.
I'm currently a PhD Student
at Harvard University.
Just finished my first year.
I have many more
Cambridge winters to go.
But it's good to be
out in California
for a little bit
and kind of shake
off the blizzards that have
just become immersed in my skin.
But I'm really happy to be here.
I'm going to do some poems.
So who here has experienced or
seen spoken word poetry before?
OK.
Solid.
So about half.
So what we like to say for those
of you who have not experienced
spoken word, for
those of you here,
for those of you watching,
is that spoken word is not
like golf.
And so when we
say that, we mean,
traditionally when
people think about poetry
they think you sit there
and you're just like, hmm.
Mm.
Mmm.
And then you go like that.
Right?
No, that's boring.
That's wack.
That's no fun.
We don't want to do that.
So can everybody snap?
All right, snap?
Two fingers?
Snap?
So if you like something
during the poem, you can snap.
If you really,
really like something
we say you do the
delicious chocolate
noise, which means you go, mmm.
Like on the top of
mouth and tongue.
Just like, mmm.
Everybody go, mmm.
AUDIENCE: Mmm.
There we go.
And if you really, really like
something, like something just
happens, it blows you away.
You're like, oh my gosh,
that happened to me,
or I felt that way.
I never thought of it that way.
We say you do Jesus,
but with a shhh.
So it's like, sheezus.
And you fall over on
the person next to you,
and it's just like, oh my god.
But please check with
the person next to you
before, because people
got issues with space,
and these are your colleagues.
There's HR people here.
So let's not get into that.
But I'm really
excited to be here.
And so I'm going to
just hop right into it
and do some poems.
And then we'll have
some time for Q&A, which
is always my favorite part.
I'll definitely stick
around at the end
and would love to
chat with you guys.
So I always like to start with
this poem, because I think
it really represents why I do
my work as an educator, why
I do my work as a researcher,
and why I do my work as a poet.
And this idea of speaking
into the silences
and speaking into the voids
that exist in our worlds
and making sure that I'm never
complicit in someone else's
suffering, that I'm never
complicit in violence
being exacted on any group
of people in any sort of way.
And so this is a means
of holding myself
accountable to
the type of person
that I try to be for
my students and really
pushing myself to ensure that
I'm not either, again, been
complicit or perpetuating
injustice anywhere,
in any form, in all
of its manifestations.
As a kid in a Catholic
family in New Orleans,
during Lent, I was always part
of the most meaningful thing
one could do was to
give something up,
Sacrifice something you
typically indulge in
to prove to God you
understand his sanctity.
I've given up soda, McDonald's,
French fries, French kisses
and everything in between.
But one year I gave
up speaking, thinking
the most valuable thing I could
sacrifice was my own voice.
But it was like I hadn't
realized that I had
given that up a long time ago.
I spent so much on my
life telling people
the things they
wanted to hear instead
of the things they needed to.
Told myself I wasn't meant
to be anyone's conscience
because I still had to
figure out being my own.
So sometimes, I
just wouldn't say
anything, appeasing
ignorance with my silence,
unaware that
validation doesn't need
words to endorse its existence.
When Christian was beat up for
being gay, I put of my hands
in my pocket and
walked with my head
down as if I didn't even notice.
Couldn't use my locker for weeks
because the bolt on the lock
reminded me of the one
I had put on my lips
when the homeless
man on the corner
looked at me with
eyes up, merely
searching for an affirmation
that he was worth seeing.
I was more concerned with
touching the screen on my Apple
than actually feeding him one.
When the woman at the
fundraising gala said,
I'm so proud of you,
it must be so hard
teaching those poor,
unintelligent kids,
I bit my lip,
because apparently we
needed her money more than my
students needed their dignity.
We spend so much time listening
to the things people are saying
that we rarely pay attention
to the things they don't.
Silence is the residue of fear.
It is feeling your flaws gut
wrench guillotine your tongue.
It is the air retreating
from your chest
because it doesn't feel
safe in your lungs.
Silence is Rwandan genocide.
Silence is Katrina.
It is what you hear when there
aren't enough body bags left.
It is the sound after the
noose is already tied.
It is charring.
It is chains.
It is privilege.
It is pain.
There was no time to pick your
battles when your battles have
already picked you.
I will not let silence wrap
itself around my indecision.
I will tell Christian that he is
a lion, a sanctuary of bravery
and brilliance.
I will ask that homeless
man what his name is
and how his day was, because
sometimes all people want to be
is human.
I will tell that
woman that my students
can talk about Transcendentalism
like their last name was
Thoreau.
And just because you watched
one episode of "The Wire"
doesn't mean you know
anything about my kids.
So this year, instead
of giving something up
I will live every day as if
there were a microphone tucked
under my tongue.
I stage on the underside
of my inhibition.
Because who has to have
a soapbox when all you've
ever needed is your voice?
[APPLAUSE]
So you can clap after the poem.
People always get confused.
They're like, oh, yeah, yeah.
No, you can clap after the
poem, snap during the poem.
You got it.
So that's the warm up.
Yeah, and so I'm from New
Orleans, born and raised.
And there's nothing
like that place.
And I'm a big family guy.
Right?
Like all my family's down there.
We have some New
Orleans people here?
Baton Rouge, Louisiana.
Hey.
Yeah, there we go.
And there's nothing
like that place.
My family means so much
to me, and so many of them
are still down there.
We've rebuilt and sort
of reinvented our lives
after the storm, which
will be a decade coming up.
I was a senior in high
school when that happened.
And so it's kind of
crazy to think of all
that's transpired since then.
But like I said, my family's
been part of my life.
And my father has had
chronic kidney disease
for my entire teenage
and adult life.
And he's had two
kidney transplants.
And two years ago, he had
his second kidney transplant
at John Hopkins in Baltimore.
And he had some complications
with the surgery,
and we weren't sure what
was going to happen after.
And for any of us who've had
family members or people that
are close to us become
deeply sick or deeply ill
or even passed away, the
idea being confronted
with the mortality of
someone that we almost
think of as immortal, in some
sense, especially a parent,
is deeply unsettling.
And for me, it really forced
me to step back and reevaluate
and reflect on who
this man was in my life
and what he meant to me in a
way that I never had before.
And so this poem is
for and about my dad,
and really stepping
back and trying
to figure out who is this
man in the context of my life
and who I've become and
who I hope to become.
And so this is for him.
In New Orleans,
seafood is as much
a part of life as
changing tides.
I was raised between shrimp
etouffee and fried catfish,
learned to walk on
crab legs and was
baptized in a pot of
Crawfish before I even
knew what one was.
Still, I was always
disgusted by the oysters.
But see, my dad loved them.
He said that the zinc in the
meat was good for your hair,
and if I had seen the
hairlines on the men
on my momma's side
of the family,
I'd better start eating up.
I would later learn that an
oyster's pearls were formed
from foreign parasites
that had reached
the boundaries of its shell.
To protect itself
from the danger,
the oyster cocoons the
substance in coats of calcium
until the very thing that
was trying to destroy it
becomes the thing that
makes it most beautiful.
Mother Nature has a
funny way of teaching us.
See, last summer
while visiting home,
I went to check on
my dad to see if he
knew the score of the game.
But when I opened the
door to his bedroom,
I saw him laying on the
ground like a broken promise
genuflecting in
front of a prayer.
My father held his
stomach as if he
had been stabbed by the
very person entrusted
to protect him.
Betrayal has never
been so silent.
There is no treason like
that of your own body
turning against
itself-- a Benedict
Arnold with a bayonette in your
bloodstream, a Judas kissing
your kidneys goodbye
for 30 pieces of silver.
See, chronic kidney disease is
deep sea diving with no oxygen,
drowning underwater waiting for
a transplant to bring you back
to the surface.
But my father is an oyster,
wears shell hardened
by going up in a place
where expectations never
rose above low tide,
has a coral reef
of a mother with the echo of
an unborn ocean on her breath,
taught him that when
the waves of this world
try to wear you down, it's OK.
We are all just a
little bit weathered.
And she has taught me that if
an oyster can turn a parasite
into a pearl, then
it is no surprise
that my father can turn a
kidney into calligraphy.
See, when I was 14 and
he was first diagnosed,
he wrote me a
15-page letter saying
that if anything happened,
I had to be ready to become
the man of the house.
He wrote, Clint, though it
hasn't always looked like it,
I've always put God first.
I know you complain because
Clinton Ward Smith the Third
makes it sound like you're the
heir to a British monarchy,
but never doubt, you are a king.
Understand that I gave you
your grandfather's name
because the most sacred
things I have ever
known come in trinities.
Clint, love your mother
like a stained glass
window in a war zone.
She can be both shield
and shard, both weapon
and protection.
Treat every woman like
you would want a man
to treat your sister.
This ocean already
has enough sharks.
Clint, don't be another shark.
My father is an oyster, clasped
down tightly on the things
he loves the most, his
family and his God.
He is a calcium encrusted heart
cradled tightly in his chest,
bears scars worn from
waves that have tried
to erode him of this world.
My father is an oyster,
and I pray that when
he is pulled from
the ocean that those
who live above the
surface will see
the brilliance of his pearls.
[APPLAUSE]
And so my father,
to apply context,
is a lovely, wonderful,
wonderful man.
I'm from South, and he's
very much prototypical,
strong silent type.
My mom was always the
koochi koochi coo.
I love you.
Muah, muah, muah.
Right?
And so I would score a goal,
or do well in a track meet,
or get an A on a test, and
my mom would come hug me,
and she'd be like, oh,
I'm so proud of you.
You're so wonderful.
You're amazing.
Blah, blah, blah.
Muah, muah, muah.
Koochi koochi coo.
And dad would come up to me,
and he would walk behind me
and be like, good job, boy.
And he slapped me on the butt.
And like, all
right, that's cool.
You could tell me
you love me, too.
I love you dad. love you, Dad.
But it was like, OK, cool, cool.
And so we were in the
hospital, and I did that poem.
And I've been blessed to perform
on many stages in many places
across the world.
But I feel like the
most important reading
of a poem I ever did was for
my mom, my dad, my younger
brother, and my younger
sister of this poem
that I had written on
Christmas Eve of that night,
two years ago.
And I did the poem,
and my mom came up
and she was super weepy eyed.
And she came home and hugged me.
Koochi koochi coo.
I love you.
Muah, muah, muah.
You're so amazing.
And my dad was in his hospital
robe, and he got out of bed.
He walked over to me.
And he looked at me, and
he was like, good job, boy.
And I was like, oh, Dad.
Come on, man.
I just poured my
heart out for you.
But no, what it's done,
though, has very much
allowed us to recalibrate
our own relationship.
It's helped me and
him, I think, push back
against our own socialized,
preconceived notions
of how men are supposed to show
love and affection for another.
So I tell my father I
love him all the time
when we're on the phone.
He does the same.
And it's unfortunate that
it will take something
like that sometimes to do that.
But I think it's been a
huge lesson for each of us.
And I'm so grateful that
I could learn that lesson
without having to lose
him and transfer that
into all the other
relationships I have in my life.
Because we have examples every
day of how precious life is.
And growing up, my
parents knew that.
And especially in the
context of this past year
and all that has transpired
with regard to unarmed black men
and women being killed
by police and vigilante
in a way that is
not necessarily new,
it is only new in the
context of that we
live in a hyper-documented
era in which everyone
has camera phones.
And these are things that black
people have been saying have
been happening for a long time.
But now, everybody has
an iPhone or an Android,
and it's brought to the
forefront of our attention
in a way that it hasn't before.
So my parents were accutely
aware of this going up.
And I think for
them, it was always
a wrestling of how
do you reconcile
the tension between wanting
your child to be a child
and to run around and play and
be curious and make mistakes,
also knowing that the way
I had to navigate the world
was drastically different
than my white friends,
and that we couldn't
do the same things.
We couldn't act the
same because they had
very different implications.
And I've been thinking
a lot about this year,
the pedagogy of black
parenting and what
it means to raise a
child in a world that
is often taught to fear them.
And so I had the privilege
of speaking at TED
a few weeks ago.
TED's a crazy
experience, because you
have the virtual reality corner
over there, the 3D printing
corner over there.
Al Gore's hanging
out at the salad bar.
It's just crazy.
Bill Gates is walking
around in a bowling suit.
It's wild.
I was afforded the
opportunity to present there.
And for me, I was like, well,
if I'm going to go speak at TED,
a place that very
much represents
a different stratosphere of
wealth and power and influence,
I want to bring a
message that I'm not sure
would otherwise be there.
And I don't want people to
not know that this exists.
I think that there
are people who
decide to purposely not
engage and to ignore things.
But I wanted to bring at least a
part of what this broader Black
Lives Matter movement is about
to the forefront of people's
attention who might
not be receiving
that message in other ways.
And so I've presented it
and was immensely thankful
for the opportunity.
And it's out in the world now.
And this is it.
One night when I was 12 years
old on an overnight field trip
to another city, my friends
and I bought super soakers
and turned the hotel parking
lot into our own water-filled
battle zone.
We hid behind cars, running
through the darkness that
lay between the streetlights,
boundless laughter ubiquitous
across the pavement.
But within 10 minutes,
my father came outside,
grabbed me by my forearm,
and led me into our room
with an unfamiliar grip.
Before I could say
anything, tell them
how foolish he had made me
look in front of my friends,
he derided me for being so
naive, looked me in the eye,
fear consuming his face,
and said, Son, I'm sorry,
but you can't act the same
as your white friends.
You can't pretend to shoot guns.
You can't run
around in the dark.
You can't hide behind anything
other than your own teeth.
I know now how
scared he must been,
how easily I could have fallen
into the empty of the night,
that some man would mistake
this water for a good reason
to wash all of this away.
These are the sorts
of messages I've been
inundated with my entire life.
Always keep your hands
where they can see them.
Don't move too quickly.
Take off your hood
when the sun goes down.
My parents raised
me and my siblings
in an armor of advice,
an ocean of alarm bells
so someone wouldn't steal
the breath from our lungs,
so that they wouldn't make
a memory of this skin,
so that we could be kids,
not casket or concrete.
And it's not because they
thought it would make us better
than anyone else.
It's simply because they
wanted to keep us alive.
All of my black friends were
raised with the same message,
the talk.
Given to us when we
became old enough
to be mistaken for a
nail ready to be hammered
to the ground, when
people made our melanin
synonymous with
something to be feared.
But what does it do to a child
to grow up knowing that you
cannot simply be a child, that
the whims of adolescence are
too dangerous for your breath?
Then you cannot
simply be curious,
for you are not afforded the
luxury of making a mistake,
that someone's implicit
bias might be the reason you
don't wake up in the morning.
But this cannot be
what defines us,
because we have parents who
raised us to understand that
our bodies weren't meant
for the backside of a bullet
but for flying kites and
jumping rope and laughing until
our stomachs burst.
We had teachers who taught us
how to raise our hands in class
and not just to
signal surrender,
and that the only thing
that we should give up
is the idea that we aren't
worthy of this world.
So when we say that
black lives matter,
it's not because others don't.
It's simply because
we must affirm
that we are worthy of
existing without fear
when there's so many things
that tell us we are not.
I want to live in a world
where my son will not
be presumed guilty
the moment he is
born, where a toy in
his hand isn't mistaken
for anything other than a toy.
And I refuse to accept that
we can't build this world
into something new, some place
where a child's name doesn't
have to be written on a
t-shirt or a tombstone,
where the value
of someone's life
isn't determined by
anything other than the fact
that they had lungs, a place
where every single one of us
can breathe.
[APPLAUSE]
And so I care deeply
about the issues
of racial and social justice.
And I think, for
me, as an educator,
I'm deeply invested
in ensuring that we
have honest conversations
moving forward
about what racial justice
is and looks like.
And I think that's
the thing that
happens in the corporate world,
in academia, in non-profits,
where everyone's
talking about diversity.
Diversity conversations, we all
just need to have conversation.
And we can be inundated
with that language
to the point where it
becomes meaningless.
What are we actually saying?
We need to have a conversation.
What does diversity
actually mean?
We've become a
world of euphemisms.
And for me, I deeply
believe that we
can't have an honest
conversation about race
moving forward
unless we're being
honest about the
socio-historical context
of race in this country at large
over the last 300, 400 years.
For me, as an educator, I'm
really interested in this idea
of revisionist history
and pushing back
against this myopic view of
what our country is, what
our country has
done, specifically
to marginalized
communities, and thinking
of when we read our
American history
textbooks, what
voices are we hearing,
and what voices aren't we?
How are certain
people be betrayed,
and how are others
being portrayed?
Or how are certain
social phenomena
or legislative phenomena being
conveyed as successes when they
were only successes for
certain groups of people
and were specifically
created to be
unsuccessful for other
groups of people?
So I think a lot about that,
and a lot of my research
is around how that
happens as a grad student.
And so a few months ago,
I spent some time reading
Thomas Jefferson's
memoir, "Notes
on the State of Virginia."
And in it, he says
very explicitly
that the slave is
incapable of love,
and taht black
people are inherently
inferior to white people.
The slave is incapable of love.
The slave is incapable of
possessing and sustaining
complex emotion.
And so what does that mean
for the person who was largely
the intellectual founding
father of this country,
responsible for, in large
part, the conception
of the Declaration
of Independence
and the Constitution,
to have not thought
that I was fully human,
that I could love my
mother or my father
or my sister or
my partner or art,
that I could have passions,
that I was inherently
incapable of those things?
And when we think
about that, how
does that fit perfectly into the
narrative arc of this country's
history of dehumanizing
black and brown bodies?
This is a new thing.
I think that's my
point, is that a lot
of people who were inundated
with my Mike Browns
and the Eric Garners
and the Walter Scotts
and the far too many names.
And people were like,
where did this come from?
Why did police just start
killing black people?
There have been state sanctioned
dehumanization and violence
against black people since
the inception of this country.
And so again, I think if we're
going to move forward and have
a conversation about how we
eradicate state sanctioned
violence against
black people, we
have to have a conversation
about the state sanctioned
violence that has happened
against black people
for centuries and centuries.
And I'm interested
in it making sure
that we're
representing and giving
a holistic account
of our history
and of the different
players in our history.
And so this poem is about
some of our founding fathers
and trying to give a more
fully representative account
their transgressions,
so to speak.
Letter to five of the
presidents who owned slaves
while they were in office.
George Washington, when
you won the revolution,
how many of your soldiers did
you send from the battlefield
to the cotton field?
How many had to trade in
their rifles for plows?
Can you blame the slave that ran
away to fight for the British
because at least
the Red Coats were
honest about their oppression?
Thomas Jefferson, when
you told Sally Hemings
that you would free her children
if she remained your mistress,
did you think there was
honor in your ultimatum?
Did you think we wouldn't
be able to recognize
the assault in your signature?
Does raping your slave when
you disguise it as bribery
make it less of a crime?
When you wrote the
Declaration of Independence,
did you ever intend
for black people
to have freedom
over their bodies?
James Madison, when
you wrote to Congress
that black people
should count as 3/5
of a person, how long did you
have to look at your slaves
to figure out the math?
Was it easier to chop them up?
Do you think they'd be
happy being more than just
half human?
James Monroe, when you proposed
sending slaves back to Africa,
did black bodies feel
like rented tools?
When you branded them, did
the scar on their chest
include an expiration date?
When you named the
country Liberia,
were you trying to be ironic?
Does this really
count as liberation?
Andrew Jackson, was the Trail
of Tears not enough for you?
Was killing Cherokee, Choctaw,
Creek, Seminoles not enough
to quench your imperialism?
How many brown
bodies do you have
to bulldoze before you
can call it progress?
Mr. Washington, Jefferson,
Madison, Monroe, Jackson,
when you put your
hand on the Bible
and swore to protect
this country,
let's be honest in who
you were talking about.
When the first Independence Day
fireworks set the sky aflame,
don't forget where we
were watching from.
So when you remember
Jefferson's genius,
don't forget the
slaves who built
the bookshelves in his library.
When you remember
Jackson's victories in war,
don't forget what he was
fighting to preserve.
When you sing that the country
was founded on freedom,
don't forget the
duet of shackles
dragging against the ground.
My entire life, I've been taught
how perfect this country was.
But no one ever told me
about the pages torn out
of my textbooks, how black
and brown bodies have been
bludgeoned for three
centuries and find
no place in the curriculum.
Oppression doesn't disappear
just because you decided
not to teach us that chapter.
If you only hear one side
of the story, at some point
you have to question
who the writer is.
[APPLAUSE]
I appreciate you guys.
I'm going to do one more
poem, and then hopefully we'll
have some time for questions.
And so I do a lot of poems
about ostensibly heavy subject
matters.
I talk a lot about race
and class and gender,
and all these different
facets of identity.
And I often do in the
context of my students.
I talk about my students and
the communities they come from,
and their families, just
wonderful, wonderful people.
And I want to always be
clear that, in discussing
these issues and thinking about
the contemporary realities that
exist in the context of race
and class and our history,
it's important not to conflate
the structural realities
with people themselves.
And so I think oftentimes even
well intentioned people will
go in and say, oh, we have to
fix these communities, which
is really them
thinking that we have
to fix the people in
these communities, which
is misguided.
There's nothing wrong
with the people.
with people in communities
we're seeking to serve.
It's that they've been subjected
to, again, state sanctioned
violence in both a metaphorical
and quite literal way,
in that they're existing
in structurally deficient
communities that we have
failed to serve adequately
for many, many years.
And so I'm always
careful in making sure
that we're using language
that's asset based
rather than deficit based.
And that when we're talking
about students, for example,
when we say something is
wrong with the school,
we're not actually
saying the children
in the school or the
teachers themselves,
because we can't look at any
of these things in isolation.
We can't think about education
without also thinking
about mass incarceration,
about housing discrimination,
but also thinking
about immigration policy.
All of these things are
deeply, deeply connected.
And so this poem is a
way to remind myself
that the young
people I work with
are brilliant and
amazing and wonderful.
And it's everything
around them that we
need to work in
partnership with them
to fix instead of this
idea of fixing them.
When the world thinks
about my students,
too often they see
caricatures of pity,
metaphors of misery that can
do nothing for themselves.
But every day, I see resilience.
I see boys and girls turn
into young men and women
right in front of my face.
I see students who walk to
school on street corners
where policeman can make them
feel more terror than talent.
But they still show up
for tutoring at 6:30
in the morning.
So often we focus so
much on the quicksand
that we fail to see what
has refused to drown.
So when you think about
my kids, don't just
think about what
holds them down.
Think about how they
overcome it every day.
Think of Janya, who turns my
classroom into a coliseum,
every word she speaks
coded in creativity.
Her poetry would have
brought Homer to his feet.
Think of Anna, who
became an honor roll
student when the world wanted
to free and reduced lunch
define her.
She is more than a form.
She is more than a number.
Think of Chris, who
has been working
every day since he was 13.
That money helps his
mother keep the lights on
so that their world isn't
covered in darkness.
My students have
turned my classroom
into a symphony
of second chances.
Every day we write
to right the wrongs
that have been
done to communities
that never had a choice.
We read to learn how to
tell our own stories,
because no one can define who we
are if we are the ones holding
the dictionary.
So don't tell my kids
aren't brilliant.
Don't tell me that they
aren't walking miracle.
My students have taught me how
to relearn every part of me.
I carry their stories like
a back pocket full a prayer.
And I leave my classroom
a better person every day.
So when we speak of them,
let us speak of humanity.
Let us speak of perseverance.
Let us speak of
how funny they are.
Let us speak of how
courageous they are.
Let us not focus so
much on the shadow
that we fail to see
what stands above it.
Let us celebrate
the best of our kids
as we would want anybody to
celebrate the best of us.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
DAMIEN HOOPER-CAMPBELL: Hi
to everybody in the room.
Hi, everybody who's
joining via live stream.
My name is Damien
Hooper-Campbell,
proud member of Google's
Black Googler network,
and also a member of
the diversity team here.
I'm going to be quick,
because I really
want to hand the remote
control back over to you
all in the audience.
I think your questions are
probably better than mine.
But I want to ask you a
couple quick questions,
and then we'll pass it over.
So the first one is,
when did this happen?
CLINT SMITH: Yeah.
DAMIEN HOOPER-CAMPBELL: You're
a very talented brother.
But when did you just
know, I got this talent.
Bring us back to that moment.
How did this all happen for you?
CLINT SMITH: I've always
loved reading and writing.
I was a strange
big-headed child.
And so when I was
in third grade,
we had our third grade yearbook.
And everybody could
say, what did you
want to be when you grow up?
And so, eight years old,
most third graders say,
I want to be an
astronaut or a fireman
or a ballerina or
a football star.
And mine was like, I want to be
a Newbery Award winning author.
I was so lame.
[LAUGHTER]
Reading and writing
were directly
associated with this
notion of discovery.
My parents had
these encyclopedias
that they kept in our house.
And if I ever had a question,
my mom would say, look it up.
So I was always just
a deeply curious kid
and learned that
spending time with words
was how I could figure out how
I would navigate the world.
But I also played
sports my whole life.
And I ended up getting a
soccer scholarship to college.
But I didn't play a lot college.
And so I kind of had this
19-year-old existential crisis
where this thing
that had largely
been the way I was
identified my entire life I
wasn't good at anymore.
I was sitting on the bench.
I would later
learn that I should
have known, because New
Orleans isn't necessarily
a hotbed of soccer talent
to compare yourself to.
But yeah, so then I had an
internship in New York City.
And I went to a place called
the Nuyorican Poetry Cafe,
the Lower East
Side of Manhattan.
And it changed my life.
I'd never experienced
art in that way.
So Nuyorican Poetry Cafe
is a small poetry spot
on the Lower East Side.
But it's like the
mecca of spoken word,
well known throughout the
country and the world.
And the first poem
I ever heard was
a woman who did a poem
about having Cerebral Palsy.
Disability wasn't
something that was ever
at the forefront of
my consciousness.
But in three minutes,
the way I thought
about an entire demographic
of people completely changed.
And to me, that was remarkable,
someone could get on stage
and tell their story.
And I entered the room thinking
about the world one way
and leave that same room
thinking about the world
completely differently.
And I was like, I don't
know what this is,
but I'm going to do it.
I mean, I'm a
pretty awkward dude.
I was never the kid who was
excited to share in class.
I was a fairly quiet kid.
And so the idea of standing in
front of a group of strangers
and being vulnerable
was unsettling.
But I knew the end product
and what it could do
and what art at its best
could do in that form.
And yeah, I was fortunate
to go to Davidson College,
a small liberal arts college.
Steph Curry was my classmate.
Shout out to Steph.
I see you.
And yeah, liberal
arts colleges, it's
all about the journey
and not the destination.
I came back, and
I was like, guys,
I'm gonna be a spoken word poet.
And they were like, OK, Clint.
You write your poems.
But I just worked
on it, and I decided
it was something I really
wanted to be great at.
I became an English major.
I just took every opportunity
I could to go to Charlotte
and spend time in the
open mic community,
and just decided
this was something I
wanted to be a part of my life.
And I could have
never anticipated
that it would become what it's
become, but I'm very grateful.
DAMIEN HOOPER-CAMPBELL: Yeah.
We are very grateful
that you visited
the Nuyorican Cafe and the whole
nine, because you are very good
it.
You brought me back to the
movie "Love Jones" for a while.
CLINT SMITH: No
Nia Long, though.
DAMIEN HOOPER-CAMPBELL: So you
touched on it a little bit,
about impact and influence.
At Google, shout out
to Google a little bit.
On the diversity
team, we talk a lot
about expanding the
pool of technologists.
We look in, we
say, well, we only
have 2% of our workforce
in the United States
at Google is black,
and 3% are Hispanic.
And then if you really
start to distill that
by who are in tech roles
and non-tech roles,
the number becomes even crazier.
And we know technology's
running everything right now,
and for the foreseeable future.
You're on the ground
though, brother.
You're there with
students every single day.
So think about impact.
How does the tech world
connect with the students who
are in Baltimore,
who are in Ferguson,
and help them to get excited
about this the same way
that you get them excited
about spoken word, et cetera?
How do we impact?
How do we influence?
CLINT SMITH: Yeah, no,
that's a great question.
I think of myself.
I've never been a tech
person, but like I said,
I always loved writing.
But growing up, I didn't see
a lot of black male writers.
I didn't really know many.
I wasn't exposed
to many growing up.
And there was one main
writer, Walter Dean Myers.
He wrote a lot of books with
young black male protagonists.
And if it wasn't
for him, I don't
know that I would have ever
been able to envision myself
as a writer.
And I've never had the
pleasure of meeting him.
He passed away last year.
But I wish I could tell him
how deeply he impacted my life.
And I think it's because I was
able to see myself, someone who
looked like me, in a role that
either implicitly or directly I
was told wasn't for me.
When I say I want to be a
writer, it's, in some ways,
almost the same as saying I
want to be a basketball player,
I want to be a football--
people are like, oh, well, OK.
That's not something
that is seen
as attainable in some sorts.
But because I had an image
of someone who was doing it,
who was doing it well, and
who I could see myself in,
it was just hugely,
hugely important
in a way that I'm only really
beginning to understand.
And so I think,
with regard to tech,
I imagine that it's the same.
I taught high school.
Kids are deeply
imaginative individuals,
but they're also human.
And so if you don't see
someone who looks like you,
or if you don't see
or are not told ever that this
is something you can or should
do, then you don't
even know that that's
something you should reach for.
If all you know of
Google is a bunch
of people who don't
have brown faces,
then you don't ever envision
yourself working at Google.
And so I think part of what--
and I imagine, hopefully
you all are doing something
like this before-- but I mean,
just literally
putting people who
look like so many of our kids
in front of our kids and saying,
you can do this.
You can.
I've done it.
And even if it's different
lived experiences,
because black people are a
very heterogeneous community,
and we all come from various
backgrounds and experiences.
But just the simple act
of being able to-- like,
if you came into my classroom,
and I looked at you,
and I was like, OK.
I could work at Google.
I might not tell you
that, because I'm
a stubborn 14-year-old and
I'm like, man, whatever.
I ain't got the time.
But that's what I would feel.
And so I think it's really
just about showing young folks
that you belong
here, and then making
them feel like they belong
here once they get here.
DAMIEN HOOPER-CAMPBELL: Cool.
Thank you.
Last question, and
then we'll turn it over
to you all in the audience.
I spent some time watching
your TED talks this weekend.
And I literally was ironing
while I was watching one.
And I put it on for three times
because it was so powerful,
and I didn't want
to miss anything.
And we do good work here,
at least I feel like we do.
And I felt inspired.
But I guess there was one
part-- the one about silence--
where you said you had
talked about spending
so much of your life telling
people what they wanted to hear
versus what they needed to hear.
You look out into
the audience, there
are brilliant minds here--
black minds, white minds,
Hispanic minds, just everything.
You have a captive
audience here.
What do we actually need to
hear, as members of Google?
And how we can create impact
to address many of the problems
that you talk about?
CLINT SMITH: Yeah.
Well, I mean, the first is to
recognize the immense leverage
that an organization
like Google-- I mean,
Google is one of the most
powerful organizations
in the world.
I was having a conversation
with some folks earlier,
and they said, as soon
as you tell someone,
I work at Google, then
almost the way they interact
with you completely changes.
And so there is power there.
And so I think it goes
back to recognizing
there's a level of influence,
both as an individual who
represents this organization and
the organization holistically.
And touching back on what I
said before, making sure we're
having honest conversations.
I think it's so important
for every single person
to be an ambassador
of racial justice.
We all, once we leave here,
once we leave Google, like
all exist and navigate and exist
in these different communities,
and some of which have
these conversations a lot,
some of which never have
these conversations.
And I think for so
long I was always
scared of making people
feel uncomfortable,
or taught to tiptoe around, just
to like not ruffle feathers.
But I had to sit back
and say, in doing so,
am I only perpetuating the
status quo that's unacceptable,
a status quo that is like
very helpful to certain groups
of people and very
dangerous for others.
And how can I engage in this
conversation in a way that's
not going to immediately put
someone on the defensive,
but also leaves them unsettled?
Because these are
unsettling issues.
I don't want somebody to sit
there after my TED talk poem
and just feel good.
You shouldn't feel good.
The stuff that's
happening is not OK.
So I think we all have to
get it out of our brains
that this should be
a comfortable or safe
conversation.
We say we want to
create a safe space,
and we want people
to be comfortable.
But what do we really mean
when we're saying comfort?
And who are we talking
about being comfortable?
about not being comfortable?
So yeah, I think
stepping out of this idea
that these conversations
shouldn't be unsettling,
because I think they should.
But at the same time, having
a level of empathy to say,
let's meet somebody
where they're at,
because otherwise,
we're not going
to move this conversation
forward at all.
And I think that
conversation clearly
should be happening internally.
But also, this is a
hugely diverse room.
Many of you might interact with
people of different backgrounds
in a way here at Google
that you don't in your life
once you leave here,
and with people who
don't have the same
opportunity to engage
with people from such
different backgrounds.
And I think that's a
certain level of capital
that you should bring to dispel
caricatures and stereotypes
and pathologies and ensure that
you're speaking up in a way
that, if your coworker was
standing right next to you
when somebody said something
negative about their community,
that they would expect you
to speak up for them in a way
that you would want them
to speak up for you.
DAMIEN HOOPER-CAMPBELL: Love it.
Thank you for answering
those questions.
Now I want to turn it
over to the audience
to see if anybody
else has questions.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
I really enjoyed
your presentation.
My question is, you
talked about reactions,
people's reactions
to what you do
and the work that
you bring about.
What have been your experiences?
How do people react,
especially when
you're in audiences
that maybe it's
a little uncomfortable
for them to hear this?
What have been those
reactions from some
of those kind of
top-tier people?
CLINT SMITH: Yeah.
They certainly
span the spectrum.
But for example, at TED,
after I did that poem,
I had a lot of folks come up
after me kind of in tears,
or really emotional.
And they were
like, I could never
imagine having to have that
conversation with my child.
I'm so sorry.
And I don't want them to
apologize to me necessarily,
but I think there is
a real gap in terms
of just an understanding of
how certain people navigate
the world as compared
to your own life.
And for me, it was
very much like, I'm not
trying to get up here and
accuse anyone of anything.
I don't think that's
necessarily productive
as much as it's like,
this is something
that is real in my life.
And I'm always ensuring that
I'm speaking specifically
for my own life, because I
can't speak for other people.
But I know that this
is an experience that's
similar for a lot of people that
I grew up with, a lot of people
that I know.
And very much having
it be something
that someone can't sweep
aside, because this is real.
And it's personal.
And it's grounded in a very real
lived experience that I had.
And as an audience
member, I want
you to understand that
and grapple with it,
and think of how does that
manifest itself in your life?
Have you seen
something like this?
When you are with a colleague
or a coworker or friend
of a different race,
do you ever think
about how they might have
to interact with people
and navigate the world in a
different way than you do?
Are you cognizant of that in
sort of everyday situations?
And so really, just trying to
plant this idea in their mind
and ensure that
it's not something
that they can necessarily
be naive of or ignore.
And so most people give
me very positive reactions
and say, thank you so much.
I have no idea.
The internet's full
of trolls, right?
So it will be like, Clint
Smith hates white people.
And it's like, all right, guys.
That's not true.
My best friend is white.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't ever say that.
No.
But I'm thankful
that people listen.
And the thing about art is
that once you put it out
in the world, I have
no control over how
someone's going to hear it.
They're like, however
many people in this room,
I'm sure that everybody got
something different from some
of the poems that I did.
And that kind of just
comes with the territory.
But I just know that I
want to put something out
into the world that's
honest, and that's real,
and that will hopefully
be thought-provoking
in some regard.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sorry, I'm
taking a Ping question now
from Erin Ross.
She wants to know, "What is
your take on activism in 2015?
Is social media the answer?
Or from your research
and experience,
do you believe it
takes much more?"
CLINT SMITH: I think what
something like social media,
like Twitter and
Facebook, have done
has really democratized
this idea of what activism
is and looks like and has
decentralized who can engage
and who can't
engage in activism.
I think there's a lot of people
kind of try to rag on hashtag
activism, so to speak, or
online activism as this armchair
activism where you
don't necessarily
have to invest anything
personally into it.
You can just click or post.
But I would argue
that everything
that has transpired with regard
to the Department of Justice
going down to Ferguson, with
regard to the new police task
force from the White House
that just came out today
that has dramatically
demilitarized
the police from a federal
level, all of these things,
in many ways,
manifested themselves
from protests that
were organized
via online and
social media spaces.
And I think, for me,
I'm fortunate to go
to one of the best
schools in the world.
And I'm deeply grateful and
learn so much every day.
But I'd probably learn
just as much, if not more,
from my Twitter timeline
as I do in my classes.
I mean, there's so
many smart people
who are creating knowledge and
facilitating ideas and engaging
with one another in a
constant, 24/7 sort of way.
So additionally,
what it's also done
is really decoupled
this idea of what
it means to be well educated
as compared to well schooled.
And so often in
social movements,
we feel like it
has to be someone
who has a PhD, or someone who
went to this certain school,
or someone who dresses this way,
or has this sort of education.
And it's like, no, actually
anyone who has something to say
can say it and can engage with--
I mean, you get
on Twitter and you
see like professors
at Ivy League schools
engaging with
activists in Ferguson,
and coordinating and
supporting one another
and affirming one another.
So I think, [INAUDIBLE], I
think it's hugely important.
I don't think it, in and
of itself, is an end.
But I think it has
really opened up
the space in terms of
who has the ability
to engage in this sort of
movement-building work, which
takes all of us.
It can't be just a few people.
I think we have this
ahistorical misconception
around how the civil rights
movement actually went down.
We're like, oh, Rosa
Parks sat down on the bus.
And then they went on a
march, and Martin Luther King
had a dream.
And then everybody could vote.
And it was great, right?
It turns into like this
week-long festival.
And that's not how it was.
It was like a lot of
people beyond Dr. King,
beyond SNCC, beyond these
individuals and organizations
that we kind of lift up who
were engaging every single day
for a very long time.
AUDIENCE: I picked the wrong
spot to sit and ask a question.
So I've been doing this
stuff for a long time,
obviously from a very different
vantage point than you.
Is there any reason to hope?
And it's not supposed to
be yes and no question--
answer rather.
CLINT SMITH: No, I think
it's an important question
to grapple with.
I think I'm someone who, while
there are certainly problems
that exist, that have existed
in this country for a long time
and continue to exist in sort
of different manifestations
of themselves-- racism.
Racism still exists and is
very pronounced in our society.
It doesn't look
like it did in 1965.
It doesn't look like
in did in 1905, 1865,
but it still exists.
But even amid that,
we would be misguided
if we didn't
recognize that there
had been immense strides made.
If you told someone not so long
ago that this group of people
would be sitting
in this room at one
of the most powerful
companies in the world,
they would have laughed
you out of the room.
And so I think that while we
know and we cannot ever think
that the problems of the past
have simply been swept away
or are gone, we also know that
things have gotten better,
and that they can, and
that they will continue to.
And that there are people who
have committed their lives
to this work, who
have like in the past
and who are doing so now
and who will continue to.
I just think if you
don't have hope,
I don't know what else you have.
Every day I wake up hopeful.
I deeply believe that we can
build a new world, that we have
and that we will continue to.
It's going to take
a lot of work.
probably a lot of time,
because we are pushing
back against centuries
of pathology and deep,
deep hatred and violence
that has been exacted
against a lot of people,
and clearly exist in its
own form again today.
So yeah, I'm not someone who
believes that the US is doomed
or that we are destined
for never moving
beyond the sort of
socially stratified place
that we exist now.
I think the work that
has to be done now
is to make sure that every
single person is invested
in that, that we can't afford
to have people on the sidelines.
We can't afford to have it so
that people are saying like,
oh, well, there's some
people doing social justice
or racial justice work.
But you know, I work at Google.
And so that's just
not my-- there
are lots of different ways
to engage in that work.
Whether it's simply having a
conversation with your family
that might not otherwise would
have happened around Baltimore.
Or, if you're in the
picket line in the streets.
I think that this
work can be done
in all different sorts of ways.
And it has to.
And I think it's going to
have to take all of us.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
when generationally we
see favorable improvements,
the challenges
of being a black male
seem to be unchanged,
how do we, as fathers,
brothers, uncles, et cetera,
educate our sons about the
world without burdening them
with the past so they feel
empowered to make a difference?
CLINT SMITH: Yeah.
Clearly, that's
been a question I've
been thinking
about and grappling
with in some way my entire life.
But certainly, very, very
acutely over the course
of the past year.
I don't have a son.
And if I'm fortunate enough
to have a son one day,
I imagine that I will
make sure that he
knows that he is beautiful and
brilliant and capable of doing
anything that he wants
to do in the world
while also having there be
a certain level of reality,
not in terms of what
he is capable of,
but in terms of how other
people will perceive him,
and to also assure him that
that has nothing to do with him.
The way people think about you,
or dehumanize you, or think
you are capable of x
or not capable of y
is something that they
have to grapple with.
And that is not because
of anything you have done,
and it's not because
of who you are.
And I think once a young
person recognizes that,
then it kind of opens
up the possibilities
of how they imagine themselves
navigating the world.
Because even for
me, I'm continuously
unlearning so many
things that I grew up
thinking about my own
community and myself
about what I was and wasn't
capable of in these ways
that we wouldn't even
necessarily recognize.
But I'm spending my days
sitting in libraries
for like 12 hours a day
thinking about this stuff now.
And I'm sitting with some
of these thoughts and ideas
and recognizing I inundated
and was socialized
under certain pathologies about
what black masculinity was
and how I should
be in the world.
And so every day, I'm
trying to step out of myself
and make sure that I
am not accepting that.
And I want to have a
conversation with my sons
and my nephews and my cousins.
Hopefully, sharing
with them these things
that I am constantly trying
to unlearn for myself.
Because again, the
problem is not the child.
The problem is the
world that perceives
the child a certain way.
Again, like my final poem, we
don't have to change the kids.
We have to change the world.
That sounded so cheesy.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: It was good.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So your art
is very inspiring.
Activism is another
tool that can really
address a lot of things.
But another tool that I don't
think a lot of people discuss
is policy change from
governments and powers that be.
But a lot of their
decision making
happens with vetted data.
And a lot of what is fed to
them is anecdotal in some sense.
Do you feel that companies,
large tech companies
like Google, have an
ethical and moral obligation
to take our resources
and the power
that we have at our disposal
and illuminate this ground data,
this ground truth, so that
policymakers can actually
make more informed
decisions about what's
happening to their people?
CLINT SMITH: I would argue yes.
I think the nature of
capitalism and the free market
might dictate otherwise.
The question always
becomes, is this
helpful for the bottom line?
Are we going to make more money?
Are we going to expand?
Are we going to scale?
And for me, it's a question
of, both individually
and on a more macro
level, what type of person
and what type of organization
do you want to be?
Just like on certain
terms of core principles.
Because there's certain
ways that companies
can and should act if they just
want to make a lot of money.
It's very clear that there are
certain things you should do
and certain things
you should not do.
But the question
is, here at Google
and around the world is, what
type of organization and what
type of things do we want to
represent as an organization
to the broader world that
might not necessarily
be quantifiable?
That might not necessarily
show up in the quarterly report
and aren't going to
be in an Excel sheet,
but that are going to send
a message to our employees
and to the world at large that
we are committed to something
much bigger than ourselves.
Because at the end of the day,
if you make a lot of money,
you make a lot of money.
But then, we're all mortal.
And we're all going to
move on to something else
after this life.
And for me, it's like, what
do I want to leave behind?
And how can I leave
something behind that
represents something
that's bigger
than myself, both as a person
and for the institutions
that I represent?
I don't know too much about
the infrastructure of Google
in that regard,
but I've certainly
heard some hopeful
anecdotes and some stories
that sound like you
have a group of people
who are at least committed
to thinking about that.
I'm here.
I'm sitting here, so
that must mean something.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well, thank
you so much for your time.
My phone has been blowing
up with questions and people
saying that they loved the talk.
And is it being recorded?
Is this being captured?
Like, we need to have
these conversations here.
So thank you for coming out.
We have a little gift for you.
CLINT SMITH: Oh, wow.
The best gift is a Google gift.
Thank you so much.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
for those in the room,
Clint has some
books for purchase
and he'll be signing
them outside.
So thank you so much everybody.
[APPLAUSE]